Cape Town is running out of water. After
three years of unprecedented drought, it
could be the first major city in the
world to go dry. And nearly a dozen more
around the world are facing the same risk.
This is supposed to be Cape Town's main dam, but it's looking more like a desert.
Did the city of Cape Town fail to act early enough?
It's always easy in retrospect, to say, well, we could've started earlier.
If "Day Zero" arrives, the South African city of
4 million will shut off the taps for all
but essential facilities, like hospitals.
In a region defined by deep racial and
economic disparity, the threat of dry
taps is highlighting the stark divide
between the haves and the have-nots.
But in the end, everyone in Cape Town could be left without water.
We're in Newlands, which is an affluent suburb at the slope of Table Mountain. Its natural spring has always
provided water for local residents, but
now thousands come from miles away, as
early as 5 a.m., to fill up their jugs.
This is now a common sight in Cape Town.
Long lines at one of the city's natural
springs, where people are collecting
fresh water in an attempt to conserve
the ever-scarce municipal water coming
from the tap. It's a time-consuming but
cost-effective alternative to buying water.
How worried are you about Day Zero, when the taps might run dry?
Some enterprising Capetonians are turning crisis into opportunity with online offers to
"deliver" water for those willing to pay.
Others are selling rainwater collection
tanks, and installing water collection
systems in homes. It's smart business,
since water, especially bottled, has been
in high demand. When Day Zero appeared
imminent, bottles would sell out in stores.
Now, many Capetonians have settled into the realization that conservation is their new way of life.
Scenes like this are not what most
outsiders think of when they hear "Cape Town."
The coastal city is better known as
a tourist destination, with multi-million
dollar beachfront properties. But three
years of unprecedented drought and rapid
population growth, coupled with
inadequate planning, have plunged this
paradise into panic. This is Cape Town's
main reservoir, supplying more than half
of the city's water.
I should be underwater right now but as
you can see there is none in sight. The
reservoir is down to just 10% of its
capacity. The last 9% of the
water is unusable because of the high
mix of sand in it, making it almost mud.
The winter rainfall runs from May to
August. But rain alone is unlikely to
save Cape Town. Instead, city officials
are instructing residents to limit their
daily water use per person to 50 liters – or
13 gallons – a day.
There are signs all around town
reminding people to conserve, and some
public spaces have already shut off
their taps. So as you can see in this
public restroom, there's signs saying
that washing hands is prohibited. In fact,
the fixtures on all the sinks are
removed, and over here there's a sign
that says, that "Due to the current water
crisis, showers and some taps have been
disconnected."
In February, farmers opened their dams to allow about 2.6 million gallons of water to flow to
the drought-stricken city. Such combined
efforts have helped to push back Day
Zero. but the doomsday remains a moving target – in a city where a water crisis
only highlights the deep disparity
between residents. What's now considered
the "new normal" for all Capetonians is
everyday life for black residents living
in townships. Under the apartheid system,
blacks were forced to live in barren,
under-resourced communities called
"townships" – like this one, where they
continue to live today. Shepherd is
among the 25% of Capetonians who live
in townships, all of which combined use
less than 5% of the city's water. They
don't have taps in their homes, or
toilets or showers.
So every time you need to get water, this
is what you do?
What about when you want to wash yourself, shower?
How many times a day do you do this? Or how many times a week?
20 times a week?
Yes.
I asked Shephard to show me how he fills what he calls his “bath.”
You fill half this up?
Do you feel like, now that everybody in Cape Town is suffering from a water shortage,
that the richer people and the white people are getting a glimpse into your experience?
Townships already experience regular water shutoffs, and city officials say they'll
be exempt from a citywide shutdown on
Day Zero. The city's conservation
campaigns are instead targeted at
suburbs, which are among the most water-wasteful.
They're also where most white residents live.
Anita Shapiro is doing her best to meet
the city's water guidelines. Her family
doesn't water their lawn or fill their
pool, and have learned to collect rainwater.
Did you know any of this before you –
No, no.
So you basically had to learn the piping –
Yes.
The water infrastructure of this
whole house.
Anita's home has more conservation signage than most public facilities. She also uses wet wipes
instead of washing her hands. If it's
yellow, lets it mellow, takes short showers
and collects the "gray water" to flush the
toilet with. Her neighbors have also
drilled a borehole and let her draw
groundwater from it.
How do you feel about the fact that Cape Town has gotten to this point of severe water shortage?
It's quite shocking, I think, to to first contemplate
the thought of there being no water in
taps. I mean, you grew up with this magic, that you
open a tap and there's water, and suddenly you have to realize it's not magic.
There's politics behind it, there's dams behind it, there's engineering
behind it, and people have failed us. The local government has failed us,
the national government has failed us.
Officials are now scrambling to construct three expensive but temporary small-scale desalination plants
that would purify seawater into drinkable
water delivered through taps.
A two-year plant seems kind of just like a band-aid and not a long-term solution.
So this is like buying time in a very expensive way?
But knowledge of the impending crisis goes back decades.
So why is the city only now taking serious action?
I asked the deputy mayor, who was recently put in charge of dealing with the water crisis.
I went to the Theewaterskloof dam
yesterday. I saw how shockingly empty it
is, but that didn't happen overnight.
So did the city of Cape Town fail to act early enough?
It's always easy in retrospect, when you know that you
had that situation, to say, well, we could have started earlier. And obviously, if we had
started earlier, we would have been in a
more comfortable position. But we would
still have to be in a position where we
had very significant water restrictions
in order to to get through this period of crisis.
During my time here, the drought was declared a national emergency. There are skeptics who say
that the Democratic Alliance, which runs
the city of Cape Town,
waited for things to get this bad in
order for the national government, run by
the ANC, to come and shoulder the burden. What do you say to that?
Well, I mean, that's pathetic, to be honest.
You know this crisis came upon us
through the lack of rainfall, and
everyone has acknowledged for the last
three years that there is an
inadequate rainfall. The national
government in terms of the South African
constitution, is responsible for bulk
water supply. So it has been their
responsibility to step up to the plate.
In the meantime the city is taking
additional steps including lowering the
pressure in its water system, installing
larger desalination plants, tapping into
aquifers and mountains for groundwater
and turning wastewater to drinking water.
So we went from 3 million people to 4
million people overnight. And so, the
ability of the city to service people
is stretched because you have this
massive growth in population, but there's
a lag in the economic growth.
What's happening here in Cape Town can't be dismissed as unique. Only 3% of the water
covering the Earth's surface is
freshwater. And already more than a
billion people around the world live in
water-scarce regions. The UN has
projected that the global demand for
freshwater will exceed the supply by 40%
in 2030, and that's due to
population growth, climate change and
human action. Meanwhile in Cape Town, as the city struggles to push back Day Zero,
its citizens are forced to change their relationship to water and how they use it, possibly forever.
Hey guys, it's Dena here at Cape Town's main reservoir.
That's what's going on with the water crisis here.
Watch our next video where you see what it means to live on 50 liters of water a day.
Be sure to like, comment, and share this video.
Subscribe to AJ+ and check out more of my reporting: Direct From.